[Musique]
on dit bonjour journalistes pour la fij
puis ça dit quelque chose à tout le
monde qu'on est la plus grande salle de
rédaction a fait au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean bienvenue au
journal la pige la publication des
étudiants en journalisme du cégep de
jonquière
plus d'une trentaine de finissants ce
relais à chaque année pour produire un
bimensuel imprimés et quotidien
numérique
ce programme a 50 ans dix mille jeunes y
ont suivi une formation depuis sa
création le poids de la tradition semble
donner des ailes ses journalistes en
herbe encore aujourd'hui un militaire va
décider de sacrifier sa vie
ils voient comme un devoir mais nous
aussi on voit un peu ça comme un devoir
c'est notre rôle à jouer dans la société
les étudiants du coin pouvait imaginer
encore récemment se trouver un travail
d'été et peut-être un jour le travail à
temps plein au quotidien de saguenay un
des plus vieux journaux au québec
créé il y a cent trente cinq ans ce
n'est plus vraiment le cas aujourd'hui
que vous avez réagi
c'est un choc je plus inquiets plein de
mon avenir d'un journaliste
la nouvelle est tombée à la mi ou le
groupe capital média propriétaire du
quotidien de saguenay et de cinq autres
journaux quotidiens régionaux a demandé
la protection des tribunaux contre ses
créanciers
les plus anciens journalistes risquent
de perdre le tiers de leur fonds de
retraite c'est quelle [ __ ] mais aussi
parce que ce casque à main spectra ne
s'attaque t dans une entreprise puis que
t'as vu c'est quand même une certaine
confiance envers les propriétaires puis
tu te fait jouer des taux ces ports
plaisent en l'absence de la disparition
d'un cotillons seigner lac saint jean
sam est une perte énorme neymar dans un
silence qui vaut qui va s'installer
malgré la réduction de ses effectifs de
près de la moitié depuis cinq ans le
journal du saguenay joue encore un rôle
central dans la vie sociale culturelle
et sportive de la région dans les
conseils municipaux
importants comme allemands par exemple
la deuxième plus grande ville on est
seuls les comptes des conseils
d'administration des commissions
scolaires on est seul le cieux pourtant
c'était très important des budgets pour
loin 801 millions de budget des
décisions qui se prennent sur des
coupures des transferts de services et
sont épatés moins de 100 on risque d'en
subir les conséquences je pense que le
rôle social est indéniable pour moi
c'est impensable de voir les médias de
capital medias s'éteindre parce que on
doit avoir une information régionale de
qualité
les finissants de l'école de journalisme
de jokers sont conscients des
transformations profondes que subit le
monde de l'information mais leur
enthousiasme est intact
lorsque quelque chose survient mais en 5
secondes ça se retrouve sur le web puis
en une journée ça te retrouves dans le
tapis donc c'est certain que à mon sens
à moi le numérique offre plus davantage
puis c'était quelque chose auquel on
s'attendait depuis longtemps je pense
que les médias papiers sont en déclin
depuis des lustres
puis s est une certaine fatalité le
syndicat des journalistes espère contrer
cette fatalité
il travaille d'arrache-pied à mettre sur
pied une coopérative issus du milieu qui
pourrait se porter acquéreur en tout ou
en partie du journal
tout le monde sait que dans l'industrie
il ya des grands journaux qui risquent
de tomber à brève échéance
donc c'est peut-être une occasion qu'on
ose mettre en place un modèle d'affaires
différents désengagement de plusieurs
centaines de milliers de dollars ont été
reçus mais cela reste insuffisant pour
l'instant
jamais
[Musique]
les apprentis journalistes voient la
situation actuelle comme un défi qu'ils
s'engagent à relever malgré la très
grande fragilité des médias
d'information
c'est à nous justement d'aller plus loin
qu'est ce qui se fait actuellement de
vérifier les faits et s'assurer que
l'information qu'on donne et les bonnes
et pertinente
[Musique]